lise thériault ministre de la sécurité
publique était avec nous madame
thériault bonsoir on vient de le voir
des images de votre conférence de presse
de ce matin vous avez vous été ébranlée
choqué qu'est ce qui vous a pas ce que
vous avez vu depuis hier le plus choqué
justement je voudrais le fait que des
femmes qui sont en situation de
vulnérabilité qui sont probablement les
plus vils de grammes de notre société de
voir qu'elles ont trouvé le courage de
témoigner comme ça pour dénoncer sur la
place publique pour qu'en fait ça l'art
est le fait que ça se fasse en
opposition parce que les allégations
sont portées contre des policiers qui
dit qu'ils doivent les protéger
ah c'est ce que c'est troublant c'est
chaque instant suppose bout pour
qualifier ces c'est comme si les règles
leggings ou toutes les mauvaises choses
s'ajoute par dessus une situation de vue
que la plupart du temps n'a pas été très
facile pour les femmes autochtones dans
beaucoup de situations
donc il est évident que ça vient me
chercher ça ne me cherchez commerce
allait me chercher comme femme ça vient
me chercher comme menace la sécurité
publique don est évident que si si on
fait pas quelque chose qui va faire
quelque chose donc oui c'est venu me
chercher que ce que vous ne saviez pas
parce que au mois de mai dernier pour
qu'on soit bien clair il ya eu une
lettre qui a été envoyée
suite à la langue de notre journal est
celle de lettres envoyées
ça s'est su il ya eu une enquête interne
la sûreté du québec
qu'est-ce que vous ne saviez pas moi
mais que vous avez appris que j'attends
chaque millionnaire bon mois au mois de
mai je ne savais rien tout ce que
j'avais c'est une lettre de madame
cloutier santé autochtone qui est
adressée au directeur de poste de la
sûreté du québec de malda mentionnant
des allégations troublant par rapport à
des événements qui se seraient passées
sur des femmes autochtones par des
policiers de la sûreté du québec de mada
si tout ce que j'ai j'ai pas de nom ni
de victimes
nina gressard j'ai aucune situation j'ai
géré y est j'ai pas de dossier avec tout
ce qui rentre ses sources une
dénonciation deux jours après madame
cloutier ont reçu un coup de téléphone
la sûreté du québec parce que dans ces
colonnes
lorsqu'on dit quand on met en cause la
conduite de policiers peu importe la
raison est automatiquement une procédure
qui est prévu
la sûreté du québec pas valda armorial
je rappellerai qu'il ya quand même cinq
mille cinq cents policiers et il ya une
équipe spécialisée qui est chargée
d'enquêter à partir du moment où on a
des allégations mais je vous arrête là
ce bout là qui ont été mis en cause à
l'assemblée nationale hier que les
commun des mortels se dit mais ça n'a
pas de bon sens que l'ins qu enquête sur
elle-même carmen depuis mais c'est ce
qui arrive est là je la trouvais sauf
sauf qu est ce qu il faut comprendre
c'est que ces politiques et à laval
d'arte enquêtait sur des policiers
souvent les gens de morières connaissent
pas les gens labour première des choses
deuxième chose pour payer cette
problématique là ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'on a mis sur pied le
but le bureau des enquêtes indépendantes
ont une directrice pour ce bureau là les
on est en période de recrutement vient
de recruter et à répondre ils seront 20
seulement qu'au mois de janvier janvier
février donc ça va permettre dorénavant
quand il y aura des années d enquête
exceptionnelle en des mecs moi j'ai le
pouvoir de demander au bureau de franck
est payé pollock
mais on est quand même en grec je
comprends il ya un débat va se consumer
la question l'autre question qui est
corollaire c'est que les huit policiers
il y en a qui était qui plus loin qu'il
décède et les les sept policiers restent
sains ils étaient encore sur les rues il
patrouillait comme si de rien n'était
jusqu'à ce matin sol assez peu
inquiétant quand même ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que deux cd allégations
auxquelles je pense qu'on vit quand même
dans une société de droit
compte tenu des nouvelles révélations
d'hier parce qu'il ya eu des témoignages
yak ne font pas partie des enquêtes qui
ont été faites et des plaintes qui ont
été déposées
on ne veut clairement que là dedans
québécois qui remonte à 20 ans il y en a
qui remonte à quelques années deux en
quelques mois il ya une femme qui doit
aller vers la sortie du québec populi
qui devait et dans leurs reportages pour
aller déposer façon témoignages c'est
pas toujours fait non plus d'inquiétude
des cas à la lumière des informations
on comprend clairement qu'on peut pas
laisser à la sûreté du québec le soin de
faire les enquêtes même c'est une
enquête qui est chaudronnier qui est
habitué qui est à l'extérieur
complètement des policiers en date on la
voit montréal et à montréal devant une
équipe spécialisée pour les agressions
sexuelles aussi donc je pense que ça
vient changer les idées
mais dans tous les dossiers sont
transférées et tout lé coach vous
regardez val d'or sera confié pour les
fans enquête au service de police des
neuf arrière donc une autre question que
les gens se posent les huit policiers
sont toujours payés il faut comprendre
que c'est des mesures administratives
techniquement parlant il y avait des
policiers qui sont visés ok dans la
panoplie de cologne un policier qui est
à la retraite policiers qui est décédé
il ya la suède policiers vivent toujours
actif 5 à valdes à redon qui sont
évidemment ils sont à la maison parce
qu'il faut c'est du corps y va car
accusés j'ai pas d'accusation lors je
vais racket dont cloud c'est une mesure
administrative dans quel sens à la
maison il ya trois autres policiers
qu'ils sont ailleurs au québec qui géra
saute toute la population soit à seront
affectés soit des tâches administratives
ou soit que simplement chez eux aussi on
avait l'impression hier mais corrigez
moi si je me trompe que les deux aussi
était pas mal prêt pour être déposées au
bureau du procureur direction des
poursuites criminelles et pénales
le fait qu'on que les policiers de
montréal vont arriver dans le dos si ça
va allonger les délais forcément non et
je pense qu'il fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que c'est pas parce que
le dossier est prêt qui aurait
nécessairement nécessairement
accusations de portées tant steak aussi
puisque on remettait en cause le fait
que c'est un enquête des policiers de la
sûreté sur d'autres policiers de la
sûreté
je pense qu'il faut être plus prudent
que pas assez
puis faire en sorte que je pense pas
qu'on va reprendre toutes les enquêtes
ces services de police avaient des
moyens qui va décider ce qu'ils vont
faire avec ça la chance certaine ils ont
des kits il ils ont des équipes
spécialisées
il ya un certain recueillement
d'information qui a déjà été fait les
dossiers sont là dont et évitant sa
prenons pas le même nom de temps que si
on recommençait à zéro l'enquète et s'il
ya des déplacements à sa faire
évidemment les positionnements rien vont
pouvoir elle à valdahon certains pour
moi accélérée c'est un problème social
est énorme
val-d'or la relation entre les
autochtones entre eux avec avec l'équipe
l'ailé blain l'abord l'alcoolisme le
taux de décrochage bref c'est un
problème social énorme je sors puis les
gens s'imaginent qu'un policier doit
protéger non pas devenir l'agresseur on
va suivre ces enquêtes là pour le reste
avec vos collègues là une enquête
précise la pas juste faire des
ballonnements mille enquête publique
précise pour trouver des solutions
concrètes c'est pour quand on comprend
mieux sur voit que les problématiques
sont complètes gildas a pris 12 à
vouvoyer les actions qu'on lyonnaise la
sécurité publique ont émis nous en place
y aura d'autres actions faut laisser le
temps aux ministres travailler
correctement
c'est complexe mais je peux juste vous
une chose ça + 12 ans pour donner une
réponse par rapport à la problématique
policière il est évident que la balance
du sujet on va devoir les aborder
ensemble et c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir
une réponse gouvernementale soyez
pointier nature voilà matériaux merci
d'avoir été avec nous ça m'a fait
plaisir à voir